hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn seven ways to
overcome bad situations and as always
guys as you're listening if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it to other people
going to be inspired as well and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself to enjoy so being
an entrepreneur is tough when a heart of
things you're ever going to do in your
life if you think it's going to be easy
you're in for a world of pain and so
overcoming that situation is going to be
part of the game it's something that
you're going to deal with on a
consistent basis and so I'm going to
share with you my seven tips on how you
can do it number one has changed your
mindset and this is a really important
one it's so easy to get sucked in and
lost in negativity that you just stay
there and spiral out of control and you
as an entrepreneur you're the leader
there's nobody above you saying hey come
on let's do this go go go that's on you
and especially if you have your team you
can't get stuck in the bad place because
you're going to bring all your team did
and they will be productive either let's
go start by changing your mindset look
at it as an opportunity to grow to get
better to build stronger anytime there's
something major that happens in my
business it sucks but immediately I
start to think okay how can I make this
better how do I solve this problem how
do I see this as an opportunity how is
this going to make my business better
for the long term and as soon as you can
break out of the immediacy of the
negativity and start looking at how do I
fix this how do I solve this how do I
get better how do I make this stronger
as soon as you start asking those kinds
of questions it pulls you into
positivity and it pulls you into the
most important part of all action fixing
the problem and actually doing something
about it
change your mindset
[Music]
this number two is rememberyour why this
is why it's so important to have a
strong why when you're starting your
business if you're just starting the
business because it's trying to make
money just reaching some kind of
opportunity this is where you're going
to quit a season start facing multiple
bad situations over and over and
repeated again you're going to quit
because you thought it was easy money
you thought it was passive income and so
that's why you got into it it gets hard
you're going to bail and go somewhere
else if you have a deep passion for it
though you have a strong why so why you
are doing this why it's important that
this is going to get done remembering
that helps pushing through the crap that
you have to deal with there's a great
interview with Steve Jobs where he's
talking about you have to kind of be
crazy as an entrepreneur to be crazy in
love with your idea because running the
business and starting it is so hard than
any sane logical person with quit
because you're you're sane because your
normal because your logical because it's
just way too hard you open you want to
deal with all this crap but the thing
that gets you through is that strong
why'd that insane passion for what
you're doing and so whenever you're down
in the hole think back to why you
started this business why it's so
important to you and you better have a
reason other than money otherwise you're
in trouble
[Music]
tip number three is model success
whenever you don't know what to do model
and success I find is one of the best
single strategies that you can do to
help you get out of your hole and so
find somebody who's been in that same
situation as you have and how did they
overcome it and I find two great things
happen when your model success and read
their stories of famous entrepreneurs
who've come before you one is you get
the tactical things of what to do like
okay Oprah Winfrey went through this and
here's how she came through or Steve
Jobs went through this and here's how he
came through or Bill Gates had this
happen in tears here's how he came
through and you get this the tactics of
specific steps of what to do that they
did second thing those I think is really
important is just the motivation just
knowing at least for me knowing that
these people struggled and suffered
early on in their careers makes me feel
like I'm not alone made me feel like if
they could do it I could do it too
so I would always start my day reading a
story of a famous entrepreneur and how
they got started now we use the top tens
because it's video and I much prefer
video but be able to watch somebody's
story hear from their advice gave me
both the motivation to keep going as
well as the tactics and what to do and
so whenever you're in the hole at least
I found that to be super helpful to help
me get out model success tip number four
is to focus on a teachable lesson so I
had a situation where I had a really
close friend of mine betray me in the
worst way possible she stole something
very important to me that was really
near and dear to my heart and I focused
on the negative I focused on the bad
situation that happened and I carried
that resentment everywhere I went
I'm not an angry person at all but I was
punching holes through walls I was
hurting myself I was angry at everything
around me and I was so resentful and
angry everywhere I went it affected my
relationship
it affected my friendships affected the
way I operated at work and I needed to
find a solution so the solution was to
focus on the teachers a lesson what can
I learn from this I have to learn how to
forgive resentment wouldn't take me
anywhere anger wouldn't take me anywhere
but forgiveness can so every single day
I worked on forgiving this person I had
to let her go
even though I haven't seen her again I
no longer hold the need to seek revenge
to see her suffer because she made me
suffer so badly I wish her all the
happiness in the world and I hope she's
doing well so the next time you find
yourself in a bad situation always try
to remember the teachable lesson and
think to yourself what can I learn from
this tip number five is find another way
and so this again is why the why is so
important you know you're down in the
hole you're struggling you're sucking
you've got you know no energy left
thinking to yourself
what I have done is not working but
there is another way to go this is what
I use really effectively in my first
business when I told my partner that I
quit when I felt so worthless and
useless and I had no value I felt like I
wasn't bringing anything to this
business and it just felt so low I
myself I woke up the next day after
telling my partner that I quit and they
said I have to find another way there
has to be another way
somebody has solved this there has to be
another way it's not that the whole idea
sucks just the way we've been doing it
has sucked and there's another path
there's another way to stay and I've
just got to find that and actually ended
up being a blessing because good is the
enemy of great if what I was doing was
kind of working I might have just stuck
with doing what was kind of working but
knowing that it wasn't working at all
meant that I had to find a totally
different path I had to find a totally
new innovative way to market my business
and it ended up being my mom and success
by going through partnerships by looking
at what Bill Gates did to build
Microsoft to partnerships and applying
that to my company and that's when we
started to get a lift but just that
mindset that this is a total failure
what's happening right now just the way
that I've been doing it hasn't been
working and I need to find another way
[Music]
sis number six is just go back to work
sometimes the best thing you can do is
just get back to work and start building
something when you start taking action
good things start to happen when you are
just negative and sad and down when is
up happening you don't do anything you
sit there and you wallow and you stay in
your head and you get frustrated and you
complain and the solution out sometimes
it's just do the work there was an
interview I was watching recently of Joe
Rogan we're doing a top 10 volume 2 on
him he was saying that if he waited
until he was super motivated and excited
to go out and go work out he would never
work out you'd be this back slob because
he never feels motivated to work out he
forces himself to just go out and do it
and so having a schedule I find really
helps me knowing what I'm doing every
day really helps me yes there are some
days that I'm inspired and motivated
excited I want to do
brand new thing and when that happens
sometimes they'll throw away my schedule
and just go all in on this new idea
because Google's going to come out of it
but on the days when I wake up and I'm
not super excited and motivated and
tough to ready to go you know I have my
calendars like this is what I in dusit I
have a schedule I know what's going to
happen and if I grind out that work
today good things are going to happen
I'm going to get close and achieving my
goal and so sometimes the way out of a
bad situation is just going back to work
[Music]
and my number seven tapers remember that
somebody has it worked both from a
global perspective you know the fact
that you are watching this video you
have access to the Internet you invest
in yourself and personal development and
watching these you know video content to
help you get better and improve just the
fact that you are here puts you ahead of
most people in the world right into the
problems that you're facing are not
actually that big compared to what most
people in the world have to deal with
that sometimes can help the other thing
that really helps me though is also
remembering that a lot of people that I
look up to the people that I that I
aspire to be like in terms of the impact
that they're having people have done
things amazing things with fewer
resources than you have right now the
people that you look up to people have
gone on and done just amazing
mind-blowing things inside and outside
your industry your role models look back
to how they started chances are they
started with less than what you already
have right now and so remembering that
and that they were able to rise up and
do such amazing things and the fourths
creativity that had to come from it
because they didn't have a lot of
resources when you're certain of
business that always serves as
motivation for me and pulls me through
that time so those are my seven tips on
how to overcome bad situations I'd love
to know which one to do resonate the
most with and why is there an eight nine
ten that you want to add to the list
that maybe I missed leave it down in the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out I made this video because a Mervyn
Bonanno asked me to so there's a topic
you'd like me to cover in a future seven
ways video check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Christie Vlad Christie thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book you're
one
words and making that YouTube video on
it as a review
I really really appreciate support and
I'm so glad that you love the book so
thank you guys for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon